la série d'exercices militaires turcs et
baptisé tempête méditerranéenne les
exercices doivent se dérouler jusqu'à
jeudi prochain soit cinq jours de
manoeuvres militaires au large des côtes
chypriotes
des unités de l'armée installés dans la
partie turque de chypre non reconnue par
la communauté internationale doivent
aussi participer à cette opération aux
côtés des soldats d'ankara
une nouvelle démonstration de force en
pleine crise entre la grèce et la
turquie sur l'exploitation du gaz
naturel en méditerranée orientale
ce samedi le président turc a affirmé
que son pays était prêt à un partage des
ressources dans la zone mais pour ankara
le blocage vient de la partie adverse on
connaît la grèce solo notre parole et
sincère le problème est que ceux qui
sont face à nous l'église nos droits se
croient supérieurs ils vont reprendre ce
n'est pas le cas il faut comprendre que
la turquie a le pouvoir politique
économique et militaire de la déchirer
le cas et les documents à masnières fils
806 choya comprennent langage
diplomatique souhaite vivre quelque
chose de douloureux sur le terrain entre
ces menaces à peine voilées et les
exercices militaires turcs la
désescalade en méditerranée orientale
s'éloigne un peu plus
depuis le 10 août dernier ankara a
déployé un bateau de prospection
d'hydrocarbures au large de l'île
grecque de kastellorizo et à deux
kilomètres des côtes turques
la turquie qui mène également des
recherches dans les eaux territoriales
de chypre pour athènes et nicosie c'est
un viol de leur souveraineté
le premier ministre grec demande
d'ailleurs à la turquie d'arrêter ses
opérations avant toute discussion
il y à de nombreux commentaires
gérer du président turc recep tayyip
erdogan je ne retient qu'un celui qui
parle d'une volonté de dialogue et à
cela je réponds par six mots clairs les
provocations s'arrête le dialogue
commence ce vendredi le président
chypriote a dit de son côté son
inquiétude face à ce contexte très
volatil
pour lui ce conflit est clairement dû à
l'agressivité d'ankara la turquie agi de
manière provocatrice à chypre dans toute
la région en fait je lui une veste
mettant en péril la stabilité et la
sécurité de la région
la poursuite des opérations de forage
illégale de la turquie dans la zone
économique exclusive de chypre a conduit
à une militarisation à tence de notre
région
le président chypriote qui appelle
toutefois grec et turc à se mettre
autour d'une même table pour sortir de
ce conflit qui dure maintenant depuis
près d'un mois
l'otan dont la turquie et la grèce sont
membres a annoncé cette semaine que les
dirigeants de ces deux pays avaient
accepté d'engager des pourparlers
une information ensuite démentie par
athènes en réaction la turquie avait
accusé la grèce de refuser purement et
simplement tout dialogue